it's march
1st 2021 so it's time for another
monthly update video where we'll talk
about what we've got coming
up in this long month of march and all
the things you might have
missed or want to see again from the
short month of february
i always begin with three big things
and so big thing number one and this is
a really
big thing about 10 years in the making
i am on track this month
to hit a hundred thousand subscribers
on youtube so if that happens given
current trends
we'll have a sort of party big thing
number two another milestone
matter we are close to the 300th
video in the half hour hegel series and
i think that'll happen this month as
well
big thing number three there have been
some changes to the worlds of
speculative
fiction series we're going to be
focusing this month just on this book
our scott backers the darkness that
comes before and i'll talk about that in
just a bit the month of february is
always
way too short for all the things that we
want to do we're coming off the
beginning of the year and you know
reconsideration of things and new
planning
so it was a very packed month and there
were some
some handicaps as well given that
uh both my wife andy and i were ill
enough to go get covid testing
fortunately we didn't have covid
but you know it put us behind a little
bit
over the course of the month we're now
you know more or less recovered
so that's good but now we're catching up
on all the work
you know classes are in full session
there's all sorts of planning going on
for the rest of the year
so what did we do in in
february actually i held a special
hegel session online link is below
specifically to celebrate getting from
the
the long spirit section into the new
uh religion section uh we also did
something kind of cool we participated
in giving fest which was a
milwaukee oriented you know sort of
set of events and both andy and i
did separate events that we we you know
kind of rode
uh heard on to you know make sure nobody
was zoom bombing or anything like that
mine was specifically on aristotle's
theory of friendship and how it would
apply to romantic relationships
i should also mention another thing that
andy and i did together
which is that we guest hosted a
special valentine's day
session of the sunday stoic podcast and
we talked a bit about our backstory
about what stoicism has done to help us
in the
you know more than a decade that we've
been together at this point
and so that was that was a lot of fun um
worlds of speculative fiction this time
around i focused on
four of philip k dick's novels and i
actually brought in a
friend and colleague of mine michael
gomez to help out with the
session afterwards we did
another friend and colleague thing with
scott tarrouli classic metal class this
time around
we focused on metal in america in the
1970s
we're getting ready to talk about the
lacing but i'm going to put that off
until
march and what else a great political
theory practice discussion that we had
focusing on student loan debt prompted
by
president joe biden's remarks here in
milwaukee at the town hall event that we
had
during this month where he said point
blank that he was not going to be
working for
50 000 of loan forgiveness a number of
other things that that were you know
events that were recorded
like the ama i also held my my usual
hegel q a sessions and we had some great
conversations there
as well and um there's also an interview
with me that came out recently that you
might be interested
on the what is stoicism site so i'll put
a link to that below
as well you just click see more and all
of these will pop
up spent a lot of time engaged in in
stuff for my classes which are going
along
more or less well you know
you know i also found out what i'm going
to be teaching for the summer
and the fall for at least two of the
places that i teach so that was kind of
nice as well
and i did a lot of uh tutorial work some
with new clients some with continuing
clients some philosophical counseling
work some
consulting quite a few other things as
well
video work as many of you have probably
seen i i've been doing a lot of core
concept videos mostly for my classes
right i'm teaching a philosophy
of life class it's titled philosophy
mindfulness and life but it's really
about philosophy as a way of life
so i had some stuff on pure adol that i
was releasing
and peter singer because we're looking
at utilitarianism and effective altruism
and then some stuff for a different
class on thomas hobbs's leviathan
i also released a i did a caption
contest and released that video actually
just yesterday
and i did one sadler's stories about the
suits that my mother bought for me
shortly before she died one of which i
actually wore
to her funeral i did a sadler's honest
reviews about this book mindfulness and
the big questions philosophy for now by
ben irvine
i gave it kind of a mixed review you can
watch the video for that i'll link to it
below
hegel we did the half hour hegel series
and i managed to produce
five more videos i didn't get to six yet
but
five more on that you know february is a
short month that's going to be my excuse
for why we didn't actually get to a full
six but it's still pretty good to get
that far
and what else wisdom for life we had two
great releases of the the video
recordings one was from the previous
month
on the aita reddit forum
but then we did a really special episode
this month where i actually brought in
my friend and colleague
john sellers in some excerpted clips and
my co-host dan and i
talked about philosophy as a way of life
and we're going to be following that up
in the future and then there were you
know videos from the events
as well so so a lot of video production
this this month
i also did quite a bit of podcast
production
i released a number of episodes on
plato's mino
which is a text that i was teaching so i
needed to do
some podcast episodes for my students
and i thought uh nice for the general
public
some stuff on seneca's letters selected
letters
and i've been releasing a lot of stuff
recently on david hume
who some of my students are going to be
reading and working on towards the
middle to late part of the semester so
that's what went on
in february all right let's talk about
march now so i'm i'm really excited
about the stuff that we have
lined up for you and i even have some
props that i'll be showing you
here and there uh tomorrow night we have
a special session of our
chapter here in milwaukee of sofia
that's the society of philosophy
in america we are hosting a guest who is
going to be talking about all sorts of
cool issues
you could say it's largely in terms of
like interpersonal communication
but he's got books on gaming and
gamification on
um on on you know critical thinking
on how to escape rabbit holes and silos
so
this is going to be a really great event
we're hosting
ct nagoyan and i hope any any of you you
know you'd have to be in the milwaukee
area to join us
pop in and it's going to be a great
conversation
on the 6th at 12 p.m
we'll have our ama ask me anything
session where
viewers subscribers whoever else wants
to pop in can do exactly that ask me
whatever they want to
if i'm competent to answer it i will
provide an answer
that same day for patreon supporters at
a particular level
we have our philosophy chat which is a
much more
intimate setting where they can talk
with me about whatever they want
to uh video conferencing if you're
interested in that you should you should
click the you know show more and
think about becoming a patreon supporter
then
uh on the 10th at 5 00 p.m
hegel q a and discussion session if
you've got questions about hegel you
want to talk about german idealism or
philosophy
more broadly you don't have to be a
supporter of the half hour hegel project
just pop in and i'll be there
later on that week on the 13th at
12 noon and 1 30 we have the two
parts of the worlds of speculative
fiction series
so i i mentioned something about this in
the three big things
we are going to be talking about this
book in particular
our scott backers the darkness that
comes before it is a weighty tome
coming in at over 600 pages it is part
of
a trilogy of other similarly weighty
tomes and it is some
super rich philosophical world building
going on there
as i was re-reading it i decided wow
there's so much just
in this that i need an entire session to
talk about this one
and then in april we're going to talk
about the warrior prophet
and in may we're going to talk about the
thousand-fold thought so we've we've
rearranged the
worlds of speculative fiction series to
adjust for that dropped out a few we
will be still getting to quite a few
uh important authors this year but that
that has two parts as usual
there's a video premiere with me talking
about the world building the
philosophical ideas biography
all that that cool stuff that goes into
those for the first hour and a half in a
video release and engaging in live chat
with any of you who want to
listen in or watch or talk about these
things and then
after that we have an additional hour
and a half of
video conferencing via zoom where we can
get a bit more
interactive and a bit more in depth
about the topics that we want to do
you probably do want to read the book
before you jump in though
it's not this this one's got a lot of
stuff going on in there a lot of moving
parts
um think about if george r martin was a
philosopher and that's
what you got in our scott backer
later on that that same weekend on the
14th
at 12 p.m we're gonna have another
political theory and practice discussion
and we're going to be grabbing a
perennial issue by the horns
talking about aristotle's views on
slavery
so that you know we'll be talking about
slavery in the ancient world and how
aristotle
uh you know says most slavery is
actually unnatural and
contrary to nature and just a matter of
force but some is
is natural how that got manipulated and
used by people who wanted to justify
slavery
later on uh both you know in in
antebellum
uh you know american south uh slavery
and also throughout the the americas
particularly south
south america to justify enslaving
native american populations
and then we'll talk about you know these
discussions of canceling
aristotle in the present as well so a
lot of rich topics there
on the 20th at 12 p.m
i'll be joined by scott tarrouli again
and we are going to be talking about the
la connection
the explosion of heavy metal on the
sunset strip and
all sorts of other places in the early
1980s so we're going to be talking about
a lot of cool bands and developments
there
um then we're going to finish up the
month
on the 25th at 6 00 p.m uh with
milwaukee's stoic fellowship we're
working through cicero's on duties
so you can find that you know link is
below
and you can also find that by going to
meetup and looking up
mke stoic fellowship anybody can join we
have people
sometimes from as far away as brazil who
join in
with us so that that's very cool i also
mentioned that uh
you know the wisdom for life radio show
airs at 4 pm central every saturday
we have some new shows coming out this
month new show episodes
and we'll also be having some as i
pointed out in the uh
three big things some milestone
celebrations when we hit them if i hit
the if i cross the hundred thousand
uh subscribers mark in youtube well then
i'll do an event i'll do some sort of
live uh chat or something like that to
celebrate it
similarly when we cross the 300 video
mark with the half hour hegel series
i will be doing some sort of event to
commemorate that i don't know exactly
when they're going to be so
you want to stay tuned to the reason i
owe calendar
or to my facebook page events uh
either of them you know are usually
updated about that
um video work i got a lot of stuff to do
this month
gonna be doing some you know hegel of
course i'm gonna try to crank out
six videos hopefully i can do that in
the half hour hegel series
got some cool core concept stuff coming
up
some of which may be a big surprise so
we're going to finish up the hob stuff
i'm
releasing those but then we've got three
uh things on diag from diogenes laertes
on the
cynics antisthenes and diogenes of
synope those are for my class that i'm
teaching right now there's also a lot of
other
cynic related content that's going to be
coming out
um from lucian of samosata
or from xenophon's um you know symposium
where he's talking about antisthenes
got some stuff from julian the emperor
who you might know as julian the
apostate from oration six
that i'll be releasing and then one of
the big projects i'm doing this month is
core concept videos on nietzsche's
genealogy of
morals so a lot of really great concept
coming out with that
i'll probably do another caption contest
since people seem to really like that
i may do some more sadler's stories
depending on
time i'm also going to be trying to
crank out some book reviews
and so i have four books that i'm going
to try to get through
and i'll show you what they are we'll
see if i actually get to all of them
cynicism by uh by allen right that
that's a very interesting
book uh here's one that i got a while
back that i i've been
you know waiting to to work on midlife a
philosophical guide
um we were doing you know the stuff on
effective altruism
so i'm gonna be doing peter singers the
most good you can do
and then finally uh catherine wilson's
how to be an epicurean
that came out a little while ago that's
that's kind of an interesting
book as well so i think we'll have a
good time with
that the events the online events like
the amas or or
you know whatever celebrations we have
there will be videos for those
wisdom for life we record those sessions
as well and you can see them
in the podcast so i'm still cranking
away on hume
content i also have some plato content
on the ion that i need to do this month
and then i'm gonna see maybe i'll do
another uh vote
you know to see what people want me to
work on
next because i don't i don't really have
a lot of stuff that i need
you know right now for classes so i
think i've got a little bit of wiggle
room
um and we'll you know we'll put it to a
vote of some sort so
that's what we got coming up in march
again all the events are in central time
if you want to join in on any of them
you can the only ones that are
exclusive are for example the philosophy
chat for patreon supporters
but everything else you can join in if
you'd like to it's just a matter of
finding the right you know time and
jumping jumping right in
using the links so that is the
month ahead and that's the month behind
hope i see some of you in these online
events and
you know stay tuned for updates about
these milestones that we're likely to
cross
you